today's Titanic tussle angel bees versus
robber beads these Central American
robber bees never trouble themselves to
visit actual flowers they make their
living at larceny stealing what others
have already gathered the robber bees
are on the offense this morning they're
going to send a reconnaissance squad out
to test the angel bees defenses as you
can see the robber bees have a definite
size advantage but this angel squad
knows how to play defense
it's a one game series if they lose here
it's all over for the high that means
the angel bees have got to go for it
they have to play like there's no
tomorrow they have to give a hundred and
ten percent have I missed any sports
cliches oh yeah they have to put on
their game face and take it to a new
level okay now here's the key moment the
angel bees flood the zone hit the entire
hive against what looks to be a badly
overmatched troop of robber bees ooh
nice gang tackling
the angel bees defend themselves without
big swarm play just like any great team
they've got a game plan and they're
executing that plan to perfection
isolate the other guys cripple them and
take them down the angel bees win it all
time to give the entire hive high-five
that's one honey of a victory okay I'll
stop